la primera bomba suicida explotó fuera
del estadio de francia en el norte del
país y después del pánico mientras los
aficionados subían del partido entre
francia y alemania- el entonces
presidente françois hollande que había
estado viendo el partido fue informado y
se apresuró a ponerse a salvo
solo unos minutos después unos hombres
armados abrieron fuego contra varios
bares y restaurantes en el este del país
en el mismo barrios desgarradoras
escenas se desarrollaron en la sala de
música bataclán tres atacantes mataron a
90 personas que asistían a un
multitudinario concierto de la banda de
rock eagles of death metal el asedio
terminó cuando dos de los atacantes se
inmolaron el grupo yihadista estado
islámico reivindicó la responsabilidad
de los ataques en venganza por los
ataques aéreos franceses en siria el
presidente alan lo llamó un acto de
guerra contra francia al anunciar el
estado de emergencia
los terroristas roban la vida de
inocentes pero también quieren suspender
la nuestra
por eso digo con firmeza que francia
seguirá siendo un país de libertad de
cultura un país activo valiente dinámico
que nunca se debe al miedo
lakhvi la vida debe reanudarse por
completo que sería de nuestro país sin
sus cafés sus conciertos eventos
deportivos y museos
en los días posteriores los dolientes se
reunieron en los lugares de los ataques
haciendo una pausa para recordar a las
víctimas mientras la investigación
avanzaba a toda velocidad el fiscal jefe
de parís afirmó que tres equipos
coordinados estaban detrás de la peor
violencia en suelo francés desde la
segunda guerra mundial la policía llevó
a cabo cientos de redadas en todo el
país pero también se hicieron arrestos
en bruselas acercándose al barrio de
molenbeek en otra señal de creciente
vínculo con bélgica los investigadores
dijeron que al menos tres de los coches
de huida fueron encontrados allí se
emitió la orden para el único atacante
supervivientes al abdeslam que se dio a
la fuga y cuatro meses después en una de
las mayores persecuciones en europa
fue localizado en mo lembeck en 2018 fue
condenado a 20 años de prisión por el
intento de asesinato de oficiales
policías durante su arresto se espera
que el juicio por los ataques de parís
comience en 2021